foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
T of this program is to provide
nutritional education only this program
is not meant to take the place of your
primary care physician the FDA
foreign
as we are letting people in the room
hello and welcome everybody to daily
with Doc if you are not already
following us on platforms other than
like Facebook we have because we are on
Facebook at critical Health news we are
also putting together uh a daily with
Doc Facebook page and Rumble we are
critical Health news on Rumble we are
also critical Health on YouTube so
whatever your favorite video platform is
for following make sure that you also
include critical Health news to those
channels that you are subscribed to so
with that being said my name is Becca
Dukes I am so excited to be able to host
this program each and every Monday
through Friday from 12 to 1 Pacific Time
one to two mountain time two to three
Central Time and three to four eastern
time here we are on daily with
doczoom.com if you are out there
watching us on one of those streaming
platforms and you want to join us live
we have a live audience here folks you
can come on you can ask questions and Dr
Wallach he's just here for us
so
I invite all of you who want to join us
here live again that is daily with Doc
zoom.com
also go to daily withdoc.com the website
and make sure that you fill out that
form and get added to our list so that
you also receive our occasional
newsletter also the replay to the
previous shows that we have going on and
we don't want you to miss it okay we've
got lots of great information that we're
putting together to add to that
newsletter all new all fresh and I am
super excited for for everything that we
have on our on our vision board and the
things that are coming to fruition
so
in addition to the welcome I do want to
say that we
are not here to take the place of your
primary care physician we are not and
our products are not meant to diagnose
cure any diseases but folks our food is
null and void of the nutrition that our
body needs to actually
Thrive okay that RDA is basically
surviving and we are here to help you
find that journey to thrive and to do
that we have a lifetime learner with us
the doctor that we
present Monday through Friday he has
he's not new to the screen he's not new
to the airwaves he has been promoting
this message for
well as an adult
60 years
okay he started doing this and figured
it out when he was only nine years old
and as that lifetime learner he has
gained a Bachelor of Science in
agriculture he's kind of doctor of
veterinary medicine he has three post
doctorates and pathology he has taught
nutrition at the college level at a
naturopathic college and he has also
become a naturopathic physician
in addition to a great teacher a great
leader a great mentor
it's just amazing what this man has done
and
when I think one of his biggest
accomplishments
you can tell me if it's one of your
biggest accomplishments Dr Wallach but
being one of the founding fathers of the
science of epigenetics and epigenetics
basically gives hope if you have ever
been told that you have a genetic
disease well the science of epigenetic
has proven that genetic theory to be
incorrect and it's done so in this book
epigenetics well thank you Dr Wallach I
just noticed you had that up but this
book right here goes through and tells
all about epigenetics and
I love this picture here
shows the kindness and gentleness of Dr
Wallach had
as a human being
in a world where
folks as a scientist as a veterinarian
as a doctor it's not always a kind
compassionate world
but he has continued to put people first
through all these years and that's why
we bring him to you and that's why he
agrees to come on he actually has 20
different zooms that he does
but it's more than that per month
um and because 20 of those are with us
each and every month at a minimum so Dr
Wallach welcome to
daily with Doc well thank you very much
um for all the kind words the only thing
I would add to that is my thesis on
twenty thousand autopsies for one for
one of my
um great um
uh
post-doctoral tips from
nihood as a National Treasure so very
very proud of that and
um uh that became the basis of uh it was
a book it came out of the diseases of
exotic animals and were actually
kind of what should I say reprinting
that book it sells for twenty five
thousand dollars each and so we're
reprinting it and let me get
yeah so it's being reprinted chapter by
chapter yeah book and so we just got a a
rough for the first chapter okay
primates and of course that's because I
found the first non-human case of CIS
abroads there's thought to be a genetic
birth defect and turned out was just a
simple nutritional deficiency at least
and um I pointed that out at Yorkie's
primate Center in Atlanta Georgia you're
at um Emory University they fired me
because I said well you're out of your
mind everybody knows let's say agent a
disease and I said no and I did the um
test on 24 other baby monkeys in the
colony oh and they also had City abroads
so they didn't have the same mother and
fathers so it was just the the managers
of the diets had changed the diets and
that's why they all had Cisco brosis and
um so you don't hear about Cesar brosis
anymore you don't hear about monsters
anymore you don't hear about sediment
death syndrome anymore because I'm the
guy that got rid of them and this is the
first that I think about 20 different
chapters in this book coming out okay
primates and I'm very very excited about
this it's really they did a great job
and it's just loaded with the pictures
and all kinds of
great stuff
um that most people have never seen
before because they couldn't afford the
25 000 book I think these are going to
sell for about 25 bucks each chapter is
going to be 25 bucks each so we're very
excited about that and uh then of course
and the newest book total book here is
um the wall of Revolution and Rebecca
has been a big part of putting this one
together with her team and um this is a
second edition and it's put together by
a team of people
um they call themselves the committee
because they were Doctors medical
doctors and attorneys and all kinds of
people and they didn't want their names
to be known so they just call themselves
a committee and this is a track record
of 75 years of doing health and
nutrition and medical research
and if we have in this some very famous
people like Pat Boone and Danny Glover
Andy young Theo Ratliff Evander
Holyfield many more telling their
stories in here so it's not just me
yammering away in this book you're
getting these very famous people telling
their stories in here holy moly okay and
this is starting to really pick up and
go out fast and so everybody should get
a hold of this book the wallet
Revolution
75-year track record of
following the message
now what I want to talk about today
thank you Becca we want to talk about
today is exercise we're going to talk
about exercise because it causes you to
sweat whether you're working in a
factory and you're moving heavy things
and pushing carts and lifting and and so
forth and shifting you sweat and then of
course uh part of of being in sports as
you exercise now I did weight lifting I
wrestled I played football I
and see here I think those are the main
ones I did in sports
wrestling football weightlifting track
okay and
um I was just a little guy I was always
a littlest one in every Division and um
I would sweat like a horse but I was
taking the 90 essential nutrients
from the time I was nine and so all
through Grade School junior high and
high school I was taking all these
nutrients I never got injured all these
other big guys are getting injured and
had to be laid out for two weeks for
three weeks or maybe for the rest of the
season and everything I'm out there just
hitting it hard and and doing well and
I've only been
six three days
in my whole adult life
and that's because I fell in a hole up
in Canada because they were walking in
the dark on a path we'd walked in for
years and they didn't tell us but they
had put a trench through there and they
didn't cover it or put a warning sign or
anything so I fell in that hole and got
punctured by rebar
and so I got IV antibiotics for three
days that's it other than that I've
never had any prescription medication
and they wanted to cut my leg off and I
said no I think I'll die with my leg on
I'm not going to let you cut my leg off
I'm glad I did that I'm sure all those
doctors that wanted to cut my legs off
they're they're dead now
um
and the point that I'm getting at is
that sweat is not just water sweat is a
soup of all the nutrients floating
around your blood
and so when you sweat either from a
workplace okay or you're exercising
you're playing in an actual game in a
sport and you're sweating just drinking
water rehydrate doesn't cut it
and that's why you see so many of these
in the newspapers today uh you're you
know you're looking at um every week
every other day or so you're finding
some teenagers some 20 year old some 30
year old some 40 year old athlete is
dying okay and they were perfectly
normal no diseases and they just died
okay and we have a set here okay uh
there's a new Bull in town uh Red Bull
of course the famous
um uh sports drink biggest selling one
in the world has only one mineral in it
magnesium we have 75 minerals okay I'm
going to leave you hold that up we have
75 minerals
OK and ours and uh 25 oz amino acids so
we're way ahead of that game and
it's one of those things where
um since CD number one there's three CDs
and there's CD number one is dead
athletes don't lie talked about some of
these very famous athletes that died in
their 20s and 30s and 40s from simple
mineral deficiencies uh CD number two is
exercise without supplementation of
suicide that is very important
information exercise without
supplementation is a suicide because
you're sweating out all these nutrients
and one of these nutrient deficiencies
is going to kill you okay and so you do
need to be sure you're taken these
nutrients and then of course the third
one is what kills billionaires the
average life expectancy of a
professional athlete in America is 56.7
Aries life expectancy of a billionaire
America is
66.3 not very good and that's because
they're exercising and sweating sweating
out all these nutrients and just
rehydrating with water don't do that
okay you need to take all 90 Ascension
nutrients minimum uh I I only weigh 142
but I take two of the healthy branded
heart packs per month we'll do something
twice a day I take two bottles a month
of the
um let's see here MSM is going to take
three at breakfast street lunch through
dinner time and then
um and that helps me with my everything
including my bone marrow to make white
blood cells and platelets and red blood
cells and antibodies so I can fight off
for bad guys including viruses and so on
and it's one of those things where
um doctors love people to exercise
without supplementing
each year in America we spend 626.8
billion with a B 626.8 billion dollars
just to treat
arthritis which is osteoporosis ear
joints each year in America just to
treat
um let's see here osteoporosis
and symptoms not to prevent or cure it
we spend 2.3 trillion so added together
we're spending three trillion dollars a
year just to treat the symptoms of
osteoporosis and arthritis because we're
sweating out all these nutrients
and very few people are supplementing to
put them all back in you so no matter
how well you eat
if you're not taking all these nutrients
to keep replacing what you're sweating
out exercise is a form of suicide
exercise without supplementation is
suicide okay you have to think about
that and when you look again a 75-year
history
of all of these things
it'll blow your mind all the things we
know and the doctors are not
transferring this information to you
okay because they have kids in college
and tuition is due people say well
you're kind of rough there well
um ask them if they've ever heard of
osteoporosis or the skull there's 37
different diseases you get just from
osteoporosis of the skull
okay and of course my favorite picture
of all the thousands of pictures I've
taken over the years
is this one the top one is a normal
skull the cranium has been taken off
you're looking down on the brain and you
see the skull is a quarter of inch thick
the second one the cream's been removed
you're looking down in the brain but you
can see the skulls is an inch and a half
to two inches thick you can see where
the 12 pairs of
um cranial nerves and the spinal cord
can be squeezed by all this extra
connective tissue when you have
osteoporosis skull this is not an age
thing babies are born with us you
approaches to the skull it's actually
due to a simple nutritional efficiency
and of course
it all kind of starts here uh this book
I'll let you know when it's available
for sale I'm going to have to read it
and make sure it's all perfect and
everything like that so it'll probably
go to press
um and be ready by the end of this month
I'm very excited about this this is the
first chapter because this is a redo of
my book that's in the Smithsonian
Institute and of course this is me on
the back cover getting the cloud
Schwartz award in 2011 for finding the
cause from instant care of cystium
fibrosis and muscular dystrophy and
sediment death syndrome very very proud
of that and this is Gerhard schroser one
of the greatest biochemists in modern
history actually giving me the award is
very very proud of that it's kind of
like the Nobel Prize about chemistry
and so very few people get this award
and I was very proud to get it thank you
thank you thank you and so we have lots
of things coming up here two more big
books okay and plus all the other
chapters uh in what is the disease of
anxiety animals you can look that up and
you can go to Siri and Syria will tell
you how many of those are available for
sale you know they're used they have
their dog ears and they're riding in the
margins and all kind of stuff and dogs
are Pete on them
and you can get some of them for as
cheap as like two thousand dollars uh
sometimes you can get them for three
thousand thirty five hundred five
thousand seven thousand eight thousand
dollars new in in the wrapper never been
opened twenty five thousand bucks and of
course the one that has
um taken the place of that for the
average person who doesn't have twenty
five thousand bucks to spend is
epigenetics this is a summary
of that thesis which is in the
Smithsonian Institute and this one sells
for 25 bucks not twenty five thousand
but 25 bucks okay but it covers all the
same information and that's a picture of
me at the Yorkies timing Center was one
of my cystic fibrosis monkeys okay
that's where that picture came from okay
very very proud of that and um it just
brings back lots of memories lots of
great stuff that um really really
uh We've saved so many kids I just can't
tell you how many thousands of kids
we've saved every month around the world
with this information so we're very
proud of that so with all that said over
to you Rebecca all right thank you so
much Dr Wallach and so I was just going
back through my communications with Ryan
who is doing the different chapters of
the book of exotic animals and I think
it's 22.95
22.95 okay 22.95 just started twenty
three dollars
for this book and it's what how many
pages 200 and something pages
yeah I think it was 230 pages in that
one yeah and so each chapter is gonna be
a little bit different because there's
more pictures than some than others and
and um uh this is like crazy but this
information
saves lives saves unnecessary misery as
many healthy years to life and it all
comes down to making sure you're getting
all your nutrients which means you have
to supplement you can't you can't get
your nutrients just by eating well
um
Bruce Lee learned that and he died at 32
in 1973 and he was a fitness Guru every
country in the world recognized it too
in the 1960s is the fitness Guru and he
dies at 32 from a heart attack in 1973
because he only supplemented with
magnesium everything else he believed he
could get just by eating well he had
false information from somebody
absolutely and just just kind of
summarize up what Dr dwalik just said
folks When you sweat you're not sweating
out just water you're sweating out all
those minerals so think about it it for
for men especially when you sweat and
you're out in the sun and you're working
in the sun you get those lines
especially if it's a dark shirt you get
those white lines well those white lines
are representing the minerals that are
coming out of your body with the sweat
yeah and one thing they can do they can
do a test a quick test you're sweating
heavily you know lick your arm and lick
some of that sweat does it taste salty
or is it taste just like distilled water
it tastes salty because it has all the
minerals that were in your blood
yeah it's not just the Dirt Off Your
Face running down from the sweat that
you're sweating out it's actually the
minerals that are coming out of the body
and whenever you had mentioned that the
very first time I heard it Dr Wallach
I'm like Oh my goodness
I lived in Phoenix we did not have air
conditioning growing up great big house
air conditioner but we never turned it
on
and I was sweating all the time
so that probably contributed that's why
you had a weight challenge because when
you're minimally deficient you're
craving you have pica and you eat and
you eat you eat eight to ten meals a day
and that's why people gain weight
so I do want to clarify that Dr Wallach
because my weight challenge did not
happen until I had my fourth son over
the age of 40 and I was pumped full of
progesterone and different hormones that
messed me up
so I went from 140 pounds to 268.
um actually I with him I gained up to
200 and then after him I added that 68
pounds the harder I tried the more I
gained so but it did lead it totally
explained Dr Wallach why I was having
the migraines why I had the body ache
all over why at 16 they were wanting to
do knee surgery and scrape the back
sides of my knees because I had
overgrowth
of minerals and of calcium calcium needs
other nutrients the cofactors
and I wasn't getting them Dr wallet
and did you know boldness disease I mean
all these different things that now I
know are directly related to mineral
deficiencies nutrient deficiencies would
you look at that
so I have gotten a great education in
the last seven years folks and that is
why I do what I do because I want to
share the information that helped me get
my life back
and that information
was exposed and brought to me by this
doctor right here Dr Joe Wallick this
way depending on what camera you're
looking at
um so thank you so much Dr Wallach for
allowing me the opportunity to be the
hostess of this program where we're
bringing this information to the world
with all the different platforms that
we're streaming on and the invitations
that are going out I was looking at the
analytics today and after the show last
night and it was pretty fantabulous
because
I get an atlas
and it shows me the dots of where the
people are that are coming to the
website
and I it was just exciting Dr Wallach to
be able to see that that we are reaching
and touching people around the world
registered in 80 countries and I'm sure
we're in a lot more than that but we're
officially registered in 80 countries
and we treat thousands of people a day
with nutrition
well and that's just where the
youngevity products are directly shipped
to or available
through the red through that
registration but folks we've got radio
we have Digital radio stations we have
the like the YouTube The Rumble the
Brady on all these different platforms
that stream information and I love the
ones that don't censor the good stuff
that's going around the world
and for me that just I mean that's one
of the reasons why I I am so excited to
get up each and every day Dr Wallach
because it's another opportunity to be
able to help somebody we thank you and
your team
for everything you do you're an angel of
God and we appreciate it
well I I thank you I appreciate my team
today I have on with me Roselle and
Sanchez is making sure all those streams
are going out just right we have Phyllis
Anderson who is one of my mentors from
when I very first started in youngevity
and she's here to help us she is or or
was very much an essential part of the
Dead Doctors Don't Lie radio program
um that was it went what almost 30 years
27 years 32 years 32 years
that's just absolutely incredible and in
we have come up with the
kind of a rebound version of that Dr
Wallach not because anything has
happened to Dr Wallach I've had people
ask hey where did Dr Wallach go was he
okay where's Char is she okay both of
them I am proud and excited to say are
thriving and and living and enjoying
life you can tell Dr Wallace right here
still smiling laughing and sharing this
information well Dr wellick as we share
this information this program here on
daily with doczoom.com
allows people to raise their hand and
ask questions so let's go to hands that
are raised and ask questions let's go
for it all right so the first person I
would like to call upon
um is calling from an iPhone go ahead
and unmute yourself I just sent you a
request to unmute
there you go hi guys yeah
uh yeah so let's see hey doctor Rock uh
and everyone else so I'm aware of
someone
I don't know them personally from where
someone that has common variable
immunodeficiency
they're around 28 to 32 years old you
know 410 95 pounds I would assume I
don't too much information on them but
they get regular uh plasma treatments
and they're bedridden muscular dystrophy
you know atrophy because they don't get
up too often and
um what could you do with that to them
to help them okay well I apologize I
missed the first thing you said you said
you had Bolivia and I didn't get what it
was
uh they have I'm so sorry about that
they have common variable
immunodeficiency
still see you know cvid whatever that is
okay so it must so it has mustard
dystrophy right
so atrophy of the length and she doesn't
move on too often and she has like a
porn in her and she gets heavy doses of
medication
um she doesn't eat too much uh maybe
some rice and oatmeal I believe soft
foods but she doesn't eat that much yeah
well yeah of course because it has
gluten in it can't absorb nutrients even
if you're taking them so that's why
she's going downhill
the first thing you got to do is get rid
of all the bad foods of course Dr
wallach's cooking without the bad foods
or 300 pages of safe recipes and safe
cooking methods doctor while cooking
without the bad foods then
she says she weighs 195 pounds
no sorry 95 I mean she's a tiny girl I
don't think she eats too much but 95
pounds okay less maybe so she needs one
healthy brain and heart pack per month a
half a dose or anything at breakfast
half a dose during the dinner time
there's 215 nutrients total and they
held their brand and hard power this
this is not I'm taking vitamin C
attitude right
she'll be taken 215 nutrients half a
dose of everything at breakfast half a
dose of any dinner time she needs uh
let's see here
um one bottle of MSM should take three
at breakfast at dinner time and they're
designed to support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
the vertebrae bone microphone itself
and
very very important because of course
the bone will produce red blood cells
and white blood cells which is the
immune system to go kill and eat viruses
and cancer cells and all that kind of
stuff
also needs a collagen peptides I'd ever
get two of the small canisters of that
so if you can take a scoop of the
morning drinks through the evening drink
she also needs the um excuse me she
needs two eggs for breakfast the
stompfield stop boil soft coats Soft
Stuff scrambled in butter not fried not
hard boiled she also can eat
well let's see here she cannot have
wheat butter on our oats or buckwheat
because of the gluten and the fago
Pyrenees in there which destroy the
small intestines but you can have grits
past President Jimmy Carter is 98 years
old and he's been eating grits every
morning for 98 years okay as Ritz or
just a a kind of a
a
what a soup made from corn ground corn
there's no wheat by our oats in it and
then also he has milk and cheese and and
butter every day with every meal
and you're not supposed to do all that
well he's 98 years old and going strong
and um you know the doctors wanted to
put him in the hospice because he was 98
years old
okay and as well if you get a heart
attack it'll be in the hospital and we
can save you you go home and you have a
heart attack you'll die before you get
to the hospital
and he said I'll just stay at home I'm
doing fine and so we'll keep track of
him because he's quite in quote doing
hospice thing because he's 98 years old
at home so that's kind of funny but
anyway now the point here is she needs
to be getting all 90 essential nutrients
and it wouldn't hurt for her to have a
rebound or sports drink with 100
nutrients in it has 75 minerals
a Red Bull has one Minerals Magnesium we
have 75 minerals Red Bull has four
vitamins we have 25 items amino acids
okay in our rebound
so in her body weight she could have say
two doses a day I'd take two doses a day
two cans a day you pop them at night
um then they off gas and put them in the
refrigerator they off gas the bubbly
they're flat in the morning so you don't
have to worry about the carbonation uh
if you don't want to do that and you
just want to make them as you need them
we do have the sticks okay there's 30
sticks in a box there's still the same
formulas 100 nutrients in here we have
the canister there's 36 servings in the
canister there's a lot of countries that
only allow the canister in there it's a
powder there's 36 servings of the
rebound in the canister and so
um this gal needs all this nutrition
okay and stay away from the bad stuff no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no gluten no wheat nose no buckwheat no
sugar no carbon or drinks even even the
diet one's got to go and also no
carbonated water no alkaline water
because they neutralize stomach acids so
you cannot absorb minerals or digest
food this is basically like kindergarten
stuff but yet doctors aren't taught this
and so that's why the patients are
always in trouble
back to you Becca all right thank you so
much Dr Wallach and we're going to move
right into the next town that is up and
that is Phyllis Phyllis go ahead and
unmute yourself
Dr Wallach always good to see you which
we never got to do on the radio so here
we are here we are thank you so much
today uh and I wanted to say I so
appreciate your comments about exercise
without supplementation is suicide yes
it seems like almost every day we see
articles about athletes collapsing on
the field on the racetrack and
um it's because they are fit but they
are not healthy that's correct and it's
because they're exercising they're doing
all the right stuff there but they're
they're drinking
fluids but they're not taking in
nutrition and if they are they love the
immediate response they get from Red
Bull because it's caffeine and sugar it
only has one mineral in it magnesium
okay they're only missing 75 minerals
I do have a question from Sarah who is
not on with us today
she is 5'4
180 pounds 67 years old
the only medication she takes is
levothyroxine for Hashimoto's
she says she is religiously following
the good food bad food list no gluten uh
so three main issues number one she had
years of exposure to toxic chemicals and
this affected her eye
uh she has flashes of light and clumps
of tissue floating around in her eye
number two She has chronic gallbladder
pain
uh an ultrasound showed no stones in the
gallbladder number three she was
hospitalized about four months ago with
diverticulosis and given two rounds of
antibiotics how can we help Sarah
okay
well diverticulosis is and she's getting
either
um
uh you know things like gluten we butter
our oats she may be eating buckwheat
with the fago Pyrenees in there she
cannot have any of that okay there are
no such thing as gluten-free oats okay
the gluten oats is called glian but it's
still gluten and then um when you when
you have uh let's see here the safety
has um had a history of toxic chemicals
so we need to do a hair analysis on her
uh get the book The Rare has been cures
to go to chapter 10 11 page 272 tell us
how to click but here we're going to
ship it and how to ship it and all that
kind of stuff don't forget to put the
check in there because the lab will want
to test without the check the
diverticulosis is due to a gluten damage
to small intestine the gallbladder can
be just something going on with the
liver with all these nutritional
deficiencies
and of course thyroid is very easy that
was my first scientific paper I wrote a
mass die off of 500 and one night okay
from a thyroid issue from pollution when
the temperature change radically from 50
degrees down to 16 degrees 500 died in
one night
from hypothermia because they've been
getting
um
[Music]
trouble
um in their drinking water nitrates in
their drinking water from the
neighboring Farms
and 500 died in one night that was my
first scientific paper published okay
very proud of that so in a hundred and
you say she was 100 and what
180 pounds and five foot four five and
four okay 180 pounds okay none of the
bad foods and we're gonna assume she
still has some toxic stuff in her so we
want her to get to to how the brain and
heart patch remote photo thing twice a
day she's two bottles a month of the MSM
so you can take three of breakfast
dinner time
and that's going to help repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone marrow and all that kind of
stuff
she also needs the two
um take the collagen peptides and scuba
that with a breakfast drink a scuba
other
dinner drink okay there'll be two
canisters per month of the collagen
peptides and she also needs two bottles
a month of the ocean's gold for her
thyroid issues okay so she can take
three twice a day she also needs either
the few coins Z which is the capsule
form of the eight or nine different
seaweeds from the other ocean okay but
if she prefers the liquid we have the Z
radical same thing it's just a liquid as
opposed to the capsules but but I take
both of them I take the Z radical and
the fuquoise Z and then I also take the
ocean's gold I only weigh 142 all right
and then uh she also let's see here
um
I wanted to have the gallbladder in a
bottle it's our ultimate enzymes we call
it the gallbladder bottle because we
take the gallbladder some cattle in the
slaughterhouse we get the bile out dry
it and put it in all of our
um our enzymes so the gallbladder bottle
or ultimate enzymes you can take the two
or three of those say five to ten
minutes for each meal with a couple
ounces of water and that's going to help
her there
but she's got to get rid of all the bad
stuff okay and again it wouldn't hurt
for her to get a hold of that book back
while I was cooking without the bad
foods 300 pages
of safe recipes and safe cooking methods
and then call US every couple weeks let
us know how she's doing in any lab tests
she gets
but this is a lifetime deal and people
will say oh I'm feeling pretty good here
I can cut back on all this no
okay do you cut back on the oil in your
car
no you still have to put six quarts of
oil in your car
okay and so you have to do the same
thing for yourself as long as you want
to live
okay back to you
thank you so much back to you Becca
um great question there
Phyllis thank you so much and and thank
you for pointing out you know on the
Airways you didn't get to see Dr Wallach
here we get to see Dr Wallach in action
not just here that deep voice somebody
has referred to him as you know because
they used to listen to to the talk radio
you know we always do and it was Dr
wallet because it was that voice like
Moses coming from the Mountaintop which
I thought was kind of a cool referral
that that's a compliment I would say
doctor there's a compliment that's a big
responsibility if uh they're looking and
of course I spent a lot of time in
Israel when I was in the military
I spent until more than 20 years in
military retires lieutenant colonel in
the Air Force but I spent a lot of time
in the Middle East
um in Israel in Saudi Arabia and Egypt
and uh when I was in the military and so
I'm very very familiar with that part of
the world so my favorite music is from
Exodus
the great great great movie
and um I just get breathless when I hear
that music because you know the Hebrews
were slaves for 2000 years
and Moses
got him out of there
and the good Lord contributed by
spreading the Red Sea so they could
escape from the Egyptian chariots and
all that kind of stuff what a great
story okay and so we have some great
stories coming just remember the Old
Testament was 3500 years ago the New
Testament was two thousand years ago and
so we have a third Testament coming out
okay we're listing all of the great
things that God has done in the last two
thousand years we're giving God the
credit for all these things for two
thousand years okay and so we're putting
it into a book we're going to call the
third Testament
oh my gosh I'm excited about that
because
these are all God things and we'll give
the good Lord all the credit
absolutely it's just documenting some of
the Miracles that he continues
continues to do and you know it's I
don't think it's an accident Dr Wallach
that you know the Exodus movie was when
was it out in 1960s
and at that time
Pat Boone who wrote the forward
to this movie I mean to this book
um also sung the theme song for that
yeah he was the one who sang the the
theme song for the movie
yeah this land is
I'm not gonna sing it I'm gonna spare
you all
um because we're gonna go to the next
question and this question Dr Wallach
comes from Jeff
Australia okay so he got the virus
that's been going around
um and he's been suffering from the long
effects of it since January of last year
and he has been relying on asthma
medications he has bad muscle spasms
Spondylitis arthritis and a really bad
back and shoulder blade
so
what would you recommend for Jeff Dr
Wallach he's six foot tall
185 pounds at 52.
okay and it's mostly joint and back
stuff right
he's yeah he's got joint back stuff and
I mean if he's relying on asthma
medications that means he's got some
lung issues going on as well okay okay
asthma also okay yeah these are all
nutritional things none of them are not
emergenetic and none of them are
autoimmune okay and so at his body
weight he needs to get rid of all the
bad stuff get a hold of that book Dr
loves cooking without the bad foods 300
pages of safe recipes and safe cooking
methods he needs to get rid of all the
bad stuff no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat to run
around oats no sugar no carbon or drinks
uh no buckwheat no well let's see here
no alkaline water no carbonated water
because they neutralize stomach acid so
you cannot absorb minerals or digest
um food okay excuse me and then
let's see here let's go ahead and give
him two healthy brain and hard pasture
months two healthy brain and heart
passionate about the photos everything
twice a day he needs two bottles a month
of our MS of our MSM so take three at
breakfast three lunch three dinner time
they're designed to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone makes one
itself he needs two of the mechanisters
a month of the collagen peptide so we
can take a scoot with that one this
morning drink a square this evening
drink okay
um then I also uh want him because he
has a an asthma issue I also want him to
get he's going to get
the efas and EFA pluses with the
with the um
but I also want him to take some extra
just before bedtime he can take another
three
um every other day the efas and every
the other days the EFA pluses and he'll
um you know the asthma will go away it's
very simple nutritional deficiencies and
of course doctors just give you a
cortisone they just you know give you
the symptom relief they don't get really
problems and so I think that covers all
of his issues
um
but all of these back issues joint
issues will go away very quickly with
this program we deal with professional
athletes Olympic athletes people who do
heavy factory work all over the world
and this little regimen does a fabulous
job we have a lot of experience with it
as you say over 65 years
and so
um we were very confident that this guy
is going to get the results he's looking
for
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and folks you hear Dr Wallach talk about
the good foods bad foods list and he
goes through and he I don't want to say
he rattles him off but he sneaks them
quite quickly you can go to daily with
doc.com and they're in the menu menu
options I have a link to help you
quickly find that list of the Good Foods
bad foods list they're on our website
again that's daily with doc.com and if
you want to do yeah I'm not going to
show that that's too complicated I have
wonderful co-hosts that put all this
information into the chat if you are
here live with us so that you would be
able to just click on it and it pulls it
up and then you can refer to it later so
hey join us live here Monday through
Friday from 12 to 1 Pacific time and
then you can figure out the other times
based on your time zone
got you Alex let's go ahead and go to
the next hand that is up and here we're
going to California
hello Bobby go ahead and unmute yourself
hello Dr Wallach and thank you Becker
Dukes for all the work you do and Paul
I'm glad to be one of your part of your
certified holistic coaches and I'm
really proud here's a question for you
Dr Wallen we have a male at 320 pounds
um he's 46 years old
he's 6-1
and the problems that is happening right
now
he snores
he stays up late eats all day and smokes
and drink alcohol
okay
this is actually quite simple
and do we know if he has any diabetes or
have a pressure
does he have any diabetes or having
pressure do you know yes he does he does
yes he does Dr Warren okay
yeah okay so you need to
get him off all the bad foods the book
The Doctor always cooking without the
bad foods okay chapter
um
a 10 and 11. because that's a different
book I apologize okay I just say that's
Rare Earth forbidden cures but you've
got the cookbook yeah we got the
cookbook okay got the cookbook
um and need to
um make sure they're getting rid of all
the bad foods uh including
um air frying even though you're not
frying in oil air frying heats the fats
and the meat to Frying temperatures
which causes damage okay can't do that
then we need to
um at 320 pounds I want them to have one
meal a day our keto Shake it doesn't
have to be the same meal every day it's
a meal replacer is not to be added to a
meal the keto Shake is a meal replacer
is not to be added to a meal and he'll
lose a half a pound or two pounds a day
with six foot one I'd like the same way
220. and so he needs to lose about 100
pounds very easy here half a pound is
two pounds a day and then
on him in addition to having
um I'd go with three if finances are not
a problem I'd go with three healthy
brand and hard pasture month the photos
everything at breakfast lunch and dinner
and also have them take the two bottles
a month of the MSM so I take three of
breakfast lunch free dinner time and
grow cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between
vertebrae bone makes about itself I also
wanted to have the collagen peptides two
canisters a month so I can take a full
let's see scoop with a breakfast drink
and a scoop with the evening drink I
also wanted to have because he has Avid
pressure
um to get three bottles a month or small
bottles I'm gonna get three bottles a
monthly the ultimate daily classic three
words ultimate daily classic tablets
take three breakfasts three dinner time
and they'll support healthy blood
pressure and healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries he's on medication for
the blood pressure uh don't pull turkey
off the medication but as the blood
pressure begins to drop in soil reduce
medication based on the numbers same
thing with diabetes don't cold turkey
often diabetes but he needs to also get
three bottles a month of the sweeties
again they're small bottles of sweeties
so you can take three breakfast street
lunch for dinner time and as the blood
sugar begins to cropping and slowly
reduce the medication based on the
numbers and usually it takes anywhere
from two to six weeks to have a very
Dynamic um positive effect but depends
on how much damage is done to his
intestines because of eating gluten and
buckwheat it may take six weeks okay
four to six weeks so
um you got to do all that stuff at the
same time got to get rid of the bad
foods to heal the intestines and improve
absorption got to be taking the dose
related nutrients to deal with have a
pressure diabetes obesity
um let's see here
um I think well he also needs the
rebounder sports drink uh he could have
two or three of those a day okay uh he
can have the sticks with three sticks a
day he could have the canister be three
scoops a day and you can also have three
of the cams a day but if he's gonna use
the cans he's got to pump the tops on
them at night before he goes to bed put
them in the refrigerator they'll be flat
in the morning all the bubbly's gone so
you could have the flat can at breakfast
one at lunch and one say four or five
o'clock in the afternoon I wouldn't go
after six o'clock it'll be up all night
and um so this this will we we deal with
thousands of people every month with
these same issues literally and so we
have seen so much success
over the period of 75 years and that's
why this book is out
okay this book is a 75-year track record
okay of the successes we've had doing
these basic things and of course as
Rebecca
as Rebecca pointed out I'm going to have
to shut this off because these people we
can't hear it Dr while I've just got
here okay
um
it's one of those things where
you have to stay away from all the bad
stuff take all the good stuff so your
body can maintain and repair itself you
can add 25 to 50 Health years of your
life if you do not take care of yourself
you're going to die 25 to 50 years early
are you prepared to give up 25 to 50
years doing the things you love to do
being with the people you love to be
with
are you prepared to give that up just
because you don't want to take a few
vitamins and minerals okay and
especially if you exercise you're going
to speed up your death because you're
sweating I've already talked about that
you're going to sweat out your nutrients
and if you're not replacing them plus
you have to replace what you're sweating
out plus you're adding new to give you
what you need for that days
um efforts
back to you Becca all right thank you so
much Dr Wallach and I know Kathy had her
hand up but her hand went down now and
we're coming up to the end of our show
Dr Wallach I know you have your next one
to get to we are so excited that you all
joined us here today
come back again tomorrow because we are
here Monday through Friday noon to one
that's 12 to 1 Pacific time and
share this program with somebody that
you care about especially if as you're
listening you think about somebody who
is going through some of the same
situations some of the same symptoms
that are talked about here on this
program that's why we do this
I personally have experienced the
benefit of quality supplementation and I
have been doing a lot of supplementation
all my life but until I found Dr Wallach
and tried the formulas that he
fought so hard to put together and
developed the youngevity company
I had had no relief
and Dr Wallach
there's nothing like getting good
supplementation so thank you for all you
do well thank you dear for for the kind
words and then the and the sort of
laying things out how they happened and
of course it's one of those things where
I always ask people do you supplement oh
yeah I take vitamin C every day you're
only missing 89 nutrients
yeah well I was doing a whole lot more
than vitamin C because I thought I was
doing the right thing I knew something
was missing but I hadn't found it yet
until I found the youngevity products
folks so I would not do this unless I
believed wholeheartedly Beyond a hundred
percent that it would work for you as
well and we invite you to feel the
difference go to daily withdoc.com if
you have never spoken to anybody or are
not working with a health coach yet go
to daily withdoc.com
you can use the contact us we've got the
store there we have all the replays from
all of our programs that we have been
doing for the last two and a half years
Dr wallach's books can be found at
www.drjwalik.com and if I could have my
co-hosts come on with me Dr Wallach
adios Amigo adios Amiga
I just want to thank
my co my Coast I have sherry
with us an amazing health coach who is
bringing lots of experience to us we
have
um and her experiences focusing on
weight loss folks so if you are
experiencing or wanting to look into
weight loss using the youngevity
products as your foundation to get rid
of those nutrient deficiencies that are
causing the weight
to stick
we we have somebody that is going to be
bringing stuff to our newsletter to help
us get through that as well so I'm so
excited to have sherry on with us we
have Phyllis
again she is
she's a Powerhouse she's a Cornerstone
she is part of the foundation of what
got Dr Wallach on the Airways her and
her husband Andy and Michael zorling are
amazing people that again believed in
the message so heartedly that they put
their necks out there and they have been
going at this for so many years
thank you Phyllis and we have my my dear
friend Ruth Ellen who has just been an
amazing support uh just it
you know when you find somebody that
you're totally connected with and you
don't know why but it just you work good
together we were up till two o'clock my
time no two o'clock your time 2 15. 2 15
this morning working on stuff to make
sure that we were getting quality
information
available
to everybody
so we work hard to do this we love doing
it and we just know that if you have a
passion for health passion to help
people
then consider becoming a certified
holistic health coach
Sherry is going to be graduating on the
25th of this month as a certified
holistic health coach Phyllis is already
a certified holistic health coach so is
Ruth Ellen and myself and as an employee
of the Institute of holistic health and
the student advisor administrator
make sure I get the words in the right
order
I can't promote the program enough
because it is changing lives it's giving
information that you can actually put
into action
in providing Solutions folks so you can
go to coachwith becca.com if you want
more information about that until next
time don't forget to get back and thank
the person that shared this program with
you because they cared enough to reach
out and share it bye for now
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign